- I'm here with the
incredible Gabrielle Union
who is on the cover
of this month's Women's Health magazine.
Oh, hello.
Oh, and yellow!
That's our signature
color here at the show.
- Oh, I love yellow. That's
one of my favorite colors.
- Okay, so Flawless, your hair care line,
is it true, I read that
in 2017, you launched it,
but then halted it, took a pause,
and wanted to relaunch the business
to a certain criteria
you felt was necessary.
Can you tell me about that?
- Yeah, we wanted to,
I wanted to wrestle back the company.
I wanted to make it black owned.
I wanted to redo the formulas.
I wanted to partner with
one of my best friends
and who is also
an amazing celebrity
hairstylist, Larry Sims,
and I wanted to make sure that Larry
was in the lab creating these formulas
to make sure that things actually worked.
And then once we figured that out,
we wanted to make sure that
it was actually affordable,
and we wanted to make sure
that it was accessible to
as many people as possible.
The first time in 2017,
I was going through
multiple rounds of IVF,
and like a lot of folks
who've experienced IVF, or pregnancy,
or any time you have major
hormonal shifts like menopause,
I had a lot of hair loss,
and so I wasn't able to
authentically promote the brand
'cause I was feeling
anything but flawless.
And so the 2020 version,
we have amazing ingredients,
salon quality ingredients,
we are affordable, and we
are being sold on Amazon
and now in Sally's.
And we just wanted to make sure
that the things that worked for me
are available and accessible
to as many people as possible.
(casual music)